Come here.
No!
Outside!
Meow.
Agent 127 breaking radio silence, I have spotted Kitty Galore.
Your mission will be revealed in HQ.
This squirrel will self-destruct, but first...
...a little dance.
Next summer,...
How you doin', big shot?
Fine! Good!
Nope, not good.
Yeah, I'm gonna barf.
...to take on a new breed of evil,...
I will enslave all mankind.
Someone's having a bad hair day.
...two sworn enemies will have to do the unthinkable.
Cats and dogs will have to work together.
Am I the only one who thinks this is a bad idea?
From Warner Bros. Pictures.
Oh, yeah!
I can't find my dog. Have you seen him anywhere?
I love being a spy dog.
This is historic. Three species putting aside all differences to solve a mystery.
Real professional.
What? I slipped.
I don't know anything I tell you; my brain is a size of a grape...
...or a raisin, either a big raisin or a little grape.
Oh boy.
Kitty, I'm home!
Is it true there's a spot on your tummy...
...and if I tickle it, your foot will shake?
Nah! That's just a myth.
Oh boy, that's it!
Cats and Dogs: The Revenge of Kitty Galore.
Awesome.
'Sup with these guys?
Hopped up on catnip.
Dude, I saw it blink.
Unleashed in 3D...
...next summer.